من جانبه قال المتحدث باسم وزاره الدفاع
الامريكيه بات رايدر ان البنتاجون لن
يتفاجا اذا واصل انصار الله الحوثيون
مساعيهم لشن هجمات انتقاميه ردا على
استهداف قدراتهم العسكريه من قبل الولايات
المتحده واعتبر رايدر ان الضربات
الامريكيه نجحت في تقويض قدرات الحوثيين
على حد
قوله
لقد قوض قدرات الحوثيين على شن ضربات وكما
اشرنا بعد شن ضرباتنا لن نفاجا اذا واصلوا
السعي لشن هجمات انتقاميه في نهايه المطاف
ينبغي ان ندرك كيف وصلنا الى هذا الوضع
فقد بدانا نرصد في منتصف نوفمبر الماضي
هذه الهجمات ورغم التحذيرات والجهود
المتعدده فان الحوثيين واصلوا هجماتهم
وعليه تشكل تحالف دولي واتخذ اجراءات
للحيلوله دون وقوع هذه الهج او ردعها في
المستقبل على الحوثيين ان يسالوا انفسهم
كم من قدراتهم سيجري تقويضها وتعطيلها في
ضوء هجماتهم المتهوره
والخطيره